nous allons donc nous relaxer célia
bonjour et bienvenue sur ce plateau
vous avez testé la méditation de pleine
conscience c'est une méditation alors je
lis mes fiches dans ancré dans l'instant
présent si j'ai bien compris c'est ça
c'est exactement ça alors moi c'était
aussi une première pour moi j'ai
rencontré agnès cordonnier ici gagnant
elle est au thérapeute et coach de vie
alors au début de la séance surprise
elle me demande de marcher dans la pièce
puis de lever les bras au rythme de ma
respiration
ensuite je devais à tapoter tout mon
corps pour faire circuler les énergies
tout ça c'est très relaxant on s'assoit
un petit peu quand même
we will be you passoire en fait on a
commencé à faire des exercices de
respiration ventrale et puis je devais
être attentives aux appuis de mon corps
visualisez vos mollets
vous de pierre déposé au sol
la méditation de pleine conscience est
une exploration dans ses sensations
corporelles
j'ai mis en éveil mes cinq sens je vous
invite à accueillir tous les bruits
environnants et les bruits que vous
pouvez percevoir de votre corps pour
mettre en éveil
votre sens de louer la la méditation
permet aussi de s'évader tout en restant
connecté à l'instant présent que vous
traversez une forêt là maintenant une
forêt aux feuilles jaunes et pourpre
à ce moment là on y entre l'évêque et le
sommeil la fin de la séance on se
réactive on se réveille un peu oui c'est
ça en fait
agnès m'a demandé de progressivement
augmenter mon rythme respiratoire secoué
ma tête et mes tirs et la séance c'est
une demi heure comment on se sent à
l'issue de cette séance c'est ça tout
l'intérêt c'est ce qu'on veut savoir
eh bien on se sent bien on se sent très
d'un mois qui est de nature un peu
stressé j'étais plutôt détendue et
apaisée
alors au niveau du temps j'ai fait une
séance d'une demi heure mais on peut
très bien faire une séance d'un quart
d'heure ou d'une heure vraiment le tout
c'est de d'être d'être constant pour que
ça marche
voilà être régulier sur sur l'exercice
en tout cas vous êtes un peu plus
détendu pour cette fin d'année 2020 est
effectivement en ce moment plutôt une
bonne nouvelle
merci célia en tout cas